[music playing]
NARRATOR: Los
Angeles, California.
April, 2017.
All right, Todd.
You got the results?
Yeah, and they're
very, very interesting.
NARRATOR: Giorgio Tsoukalos is
online with anthropologist Dr.
Todd Disotell to receive
the results of a DNA test
that was performed on
an elongated skull.
TODD DISOTELL: They did get a
good, clean DNA profile from
the maternally inherited DNA.
So this particular specimen
is actually not found
in the new world, not found
amongst Native Americans,
and it's typically
found amongst Europeans
and Middle Easterners.
In fact, the hundred
percent match
was to a Scottish individual.
This makes no sense whatsoever.
Really?
In a South American skull?
This is all very strange.
That could mean that
people from Europe
got to South America, you know,
1,500 years earlier than we
currently understand that.
That's amazing.
Unfortunately, the
condition of the sample
did not yield any y-chromosome,
but that's not surprising.
There is between a couple
hundred to a couple
thousand times as much maternal
DNA in every cell of the body.
So what does that mean?
What have we not found
out because of that?
Well, so one, that would
allow us to definitively
determine the sex.
And knowing who the
father was would
be very, very informative.
Unfortunately,
we're missing that.
Right.
Do you think that a
case can be made at all,
and again, this is complete
speculation, that perhaps
it is not necessarily human?
Is that a possibility?
TODD DISOTELL:
Well, it's possible.
But still, we actually
don't know what this is.
Since we didn't get
any definitive result--
obviously, a scientist always
wants to try to do that.
- This is extraordinary.
- Yeah.
But still leaves open the
possibility of something
interesting.
- Right.
So I think that we have
something here that definitely
merits further investigation.
That it's worthy of
study or opening up
a new area of inquiry
and some new hypotheses.
And the results
confirmed the fact
that there is a mystery there.
First of all, we
couldn't figure out who
the father is of that thing.
Number two, it has
the European DNA--
two things that make no sense.
And it had a missing
sagittal suture.
So I do think that that is
an extraterrestrial skull.